let's go to our next caller from the
four-to-three area code four two three
go ahead good afternoon
did it impact any how are you I'm doing
fine I'm Dale from East Tennessee and
I'm very concerned about the way that
we're treating immigrants in our country
yeah and I want your opinion on but do
you think the normalization of
immigration camps is imminent and if you
see any parallels with camps that they
have in other countries such as
Australia so let's see I do let's talk
first about the normalization stuff we
are experiencing hyper normalization
okay if five years ago without the slide
to where we are today we had said from
today to the next day we are going to an
administration that's regularly
attacking individual media outlets
attacking individual private companies
whether it's Amazon or harley-davidson
or Jack Daniels or whoever else threats
to require licensing of journalists
which could be revoked unilateral
suggestions that we ignore due process
in the Constitution and start just
making decisions without people getting
trials or even attorneys if I said this
is where we're going tomorrow you would
have widespread outrage and people would
hopefully be out in the streets but it's
been a slow burn it started slowly with
fake news and the other little chipping
chipping chipping away and because it's
scandal o'clock every day we've seen the
normalization of horrible horrible
things and I would not some people are
saying to me David don't worry we're
never gonna normalize kids and cages I
don't know that I buy that Dale I think
that there is a chance that if this just
continues long enough and three or four
new scandals come up which they will in
the next couple of weeks that even the
pudding of children in cages is going to
become normalized and I am as horrified
as it sounds like you are about it ya
know it terrifies me and I'm just
worried about the slipping of our rights
every day no question and what I'm sorry
what was part two of the question well
you know Australia
they have some camps you know it's
become someone normalized over there
they don't talk about it in politics
very much and I was wondering you know
anything about that and if you think
that's where we're going yeah I don't
know anything specifically about those
camps but I'm not at all surprised that
it's become normalized humans are
incredibly flexible as a species and
psychologically and we can get used to
almost anything as being the new normal
and I would be absolutely fearful of
that happening Dale thanks for the call
I really appreciate it thank you David